some breaking news this evening and
scientists are saying water
could be more common on the moon than
previously thought the discovery could
boost
nasa's hopes for future lunar missions
our science correspondent thomas moore
joins me now
so thomas all very exciting what's the
significance of the discovery for
future exploration of the moon
so they want to find water on the moon
for two reasons one is that it might
sustain
a future base on the moon uh with
astronauts returning there in 2024 but
also that water itself
might be used to create a rocket fuel
that could take
uh human beings further towards mars and
so on so this is significant they knew
that there was moon
in the shadows on the deep uh shadows of
the the polar
uh regions of the moon but now it's on
the sunny side not in great quantities
it has to be said
uh if you imagine a one meter by one
meter by one meter cube
you would get about a drinks cans worth
of water out of it and
they're not sure how accessible it would
actually be
but nevertheless it raises an intriguing
series of questions one is how does the
water get there it's
constantly replenished because the
temperature on the sunny side of the
moon is 120 degrees celsius
so they think possibly that it's just
meteorites which are raining down on the
surface
bringing water from further out in space
or it's possible that the solar wind in
itself
actually brings hydrogen which then
reacts with
oxygen in the minerals of the rocks and
and the two together then
uh create a chemical reaction and that
leads to the water
which is probably stored in micro beads
inside the
the surface so it does raise intriguing
possibilities
does this change the picture no i think
it's going to be a lot easier to go to
the ice
at the poles and extract that and that's
what the astronauts in 2024 will be
living on
okay thomas thank you